За останні кілька років Україна створила антикорупційну інфраструктуру, яка не має аналогів у Європі чи, можливо, навіть у всьому світі.
Про це в інтерв’ю журналістам заявив президент Володимир Зеленський.
Антикорупційна інфраструктура України має такий вигляд. В її основі - 6 органів.
Національне антикорупційне бюро України (НАБУ),
Національне агентство з питань запобігання корупції (НАЗК),
Спеціалізована антикорупційна прокуратура (САП),
Національне агентство України з питань виявлення, розшуку та управління активами, одержаними від корупційних та інших злочинів (АРМА),
Державне бюро розслідувань (ДБР) та Вищий антикорупційний суд (ВАС).
Ті чи інші аналоги цих інституцій, які займаються як превенцією, тобто попередженням корупції, так і розслідуванням корупційних справ,
є в усіх західних країнах. Просто з іншими акцентами та структурним розподілом залежно від рівня корупції в тій чи іншій країні.
Наприклад, Латвія. Там є агентство щодо попередження і боротьби з корупцією, називається воно KNAB скорочено.
В Румунії є дуже відоме на весь світ, мабуть, після гучного скандалу зі звільненням директорки директорату з боротьби з корупцією.
Але цей директорат займався і розслідуванням, і процесуальним керівництвом, але вважався незалежною частиною загальної прокуратури Румунії.
В Україні ж ці функції розділені між НАБУ і САП, яка є частиною прокуратури загалом.
У багатьох країнах, де рівень корупції суттєво менший, дуже часто антикорупційні підрозділи є частиною прокуратури або навіть поліції.
Якщо говорити про поліцію, можна тут згадати Португалію або навіть Бельгію.
Там у рамках федеральної поліції є спеціальний підрозділ, який цим займається.
Питання організації антикорупційних органів залежить від особливостей конкретної держави.
Чому в Україні довелося створювати стільки структур?
Просто якщо об’єднати максимум функцій в одному місці, зокрема запобігання корупції, розслідування, процесуальне керівництво,
то тиск на керівника цього органу був би просто шаленим.
А коли є декілька структур, то знайти можливості впливу вже значно складніше.
Антикорупційні органи в Україні вибудовувалися за прикладом західних структур, але із врахуванням українських реалій.
Приміром, на Заході суди у своїй основі вже антикорупційні.
Але в Україні геть інша ситуація, і є величезні проблеми з корупцією в судах. Судова реформа триває вже декілька років, але без значних досягнень.
Тому і створили Вищий антикорупційний суд, щоб швидше почалися зрушення. Вже майже два роки, як він працює.
До його запуску майже не було рішень щодо високопосадовців. Нині вже є десятки вироків з реальними тюремними строками.
Втім, до ефективності антикорупційних органів чимало питань.
Приміром, за словами експертів, спершу діяльність НАЗК мала політичне забарвлення і фактично саботувалася перевірка декларацій політиків.
Нині ж конкурс на обрання керівника САП фактично заморожений, досі не визначено, як мають призначати керівника НАБУ
і немає постійного керівника в АРМА.
Через все це втрачається дорогоцінний час, що впливає на ефективність і результати.
Крім того, політичний тиск на антикорупційні органи все ще перешкоджає їхній роботі.
Майже 200 депутатів підписувалися під документом про необхідність звільнення пана Ситника, тоді як в законі взагалі немає такої процедури.
Єдина процедура, за якої його можна було звільнити, - це незалежний аудит. Це теж елементи тиску, які відбуваються.
Постійні заяви, постійні спроби обмежити їхню юрисдикцію, зменшити кількість можливостей далі залишається.
До прикладу, якщо говорити про НАБУ, незважаючи на те, що в законодавстві вже була передбачена норма про забезпечення НАБУ
можливості незалежно проводити так звану прослушку, вона досі відсутня.
Тому що вони повинні це узгодити з СБУ, а узгодження десь загубилося і досі не відбулося.
За даними останнього Індексу сприйняття корупції, Україна перебуває на 117 місці разом із Сьєрра-Леоне та Замбією, маючи лише 33 бали зі 100.
Україну випереджають усі сусіди, зокрема Молдова і навіть Білорусь.
Гірша ситуація лише у Росії - 30 балів. А найкраща у Польщі - 56 балів.
Твердження Зеленського лише частково вірне.
За кількістю окремих антикорупційних органів Україна справді не має аналогів,
але за своїми функціями ці органи аналогічні європейським, просто структурно організовані по-іншому.
Та найголовніша проблема - кількість українських антикорупційних органів поки так і  не переросла в якість,
передусім через намагання попередньої і нинішньої влади контролювати ці структури і використовувати їх проти своїх політичних конкурентів.